now i would like to welcome dr shamir
khade he would be talking on pharma and
ai integration of omics and clinical
data
dr shamir khadir is a senior director of
advanced analytics data science and
bioinformatics at astrazeneca
a global science-led
biopharmaceuticals company at
astrazeneca he leads a global team of
data scientists biomedical scientists
statisticians and software engineers as
well over to you dr sharma
thank you thank you for the kind
introduction and thanks again elia for
hosting me today
on this uh in a sunday but i can already
see that there are more than 100
activities in the talk so i know the
science is strong here
kudos to you and the team for organizing
such a wonderful presentation
from for meeting let me just get this
slide
okay can you see my slide
yep we can see this line great i just
want to make sure i share
okay it should be fine
okay you can see my slides right
perfect
okay uh yeah thanks again i'm here to
talk about uh two of my favorite things
like about uh you know pharmaceutical
industry in general and also about ai
and then you know in in a sense what i'm
going to do today is kind of give a
little bit of a background about why
this is important why is it is is right
now at the moment for
these you know two
sectors to kind of come together and
with the specific example of you know uh
how omix data or for that matter multi
or mixed data and clinical data that we
typically generate one will be generated
in an experimental setting whereas the
other will be mostly generated in a
clinical setting how and why we need to
put them together so so this is more of
a
pedagogical style talk the reason is
that alia and the organizers kind of
mentioned that there will be like a
large number of students attending this
meeting so uh rather than brand new data
what i'm going to share is some of the
published work and then also show
how we are developing some advanced
analytic solutions to address some of
the current challenges in integrating
these types of data using a combination
of machine learning and machine
intelligence approach
so my
group's research focus where
primarily can be divided into sort of
three main themes like translational
bioinformatics computational medicine
and healthcare data science but the
group my leader machine learning
research group and the focus really is
to is to leverage
high dimensional multi-scale data to
design uh develop and
repurpose
new therapies that's the single line of
research focus but how do we do this we
are a computational team we are
from the get go leverage advanced
machine learning approaches what we
really wanted to do is we really want to
you know sort of
close the gap between the way we
generate data the way we interpret data
for for many of you who are in this call
is very much familiar that you know the
current era of biology especially i
would love to call it digital biology is
moving at a very fast
scale and pace but at the same time if
you go into a hospital you'll be still
measured your blood pressure using a
blood pressure cuff that's you know i
don't know 60 or 100 years old or you're
using a stereoscope that's like you know
100 years old older technology but how
can we bring these
two you know rather you know different
worlds together maybe maybe we could
help here as a group of you know data
scientists machine learning scientists
we could help with the combination of
data and technologies and why why data
is important and you know you might have
heard about big data something called
deep data but for me data at any scale
or any
any grade level range of quality is
interesting whether it's big deep small
or data crumbs doesn't matter as you can
see that these are some of the world's
most popular magazines all the way from
fortune to wired to popular science to
economics and then also two of the
leading uh science gen they all talk
about data can bring in value but i
would tell you that it's it's not just
the data it's about what question you
ask with this and what tools do you use
to mine this data and then we'll see
some examples as we go forward today and
let's kind of come back from that uh you
know specifically to
the setting in biology like for for
example from you know if you want to go
from
a disease for say for example diabetes
diabetes to a mechanism a mechanism to a
therapy and therapy we will bring it to
the patient and then you know a patient
gets a better outcome can that drug be
working for something else and a good
example would be like you know a classic
example would be met for me like that
but then what happened is that we're
seeing a paradigm shift thanks to you
know both the technology aspects as well
as improvement in in biological
profiling technologies as well so there
are like you know both uh the scientific
as well as the technology
is in the incident paradigm shift here
so for example we are moving from a
traditional data type to evolving data
type you don't need to have all of your
data in one location to do centralized
analytics you can now do decentralized
analytics you can go from gbs or tvs and
data to petabytes and extra bytes of
data your data can be structured can be
semi-structured or unstructured you can
use you know nlp text mining and other
types of techniques to bring structure
to your data the data model could be a
step you know in olden days like i still
remember like when we do a health
informatics project we need a stable
data model that's gone that time is gone
now
your data model could be evolving flat
data model data is moving from a low
dimensional to high dimensional and
statistical approaches
you know and hypothesis-based approaches
are now kind of moving to more machine
learning or deep learning based
approaches i'm not saying one is better
than the other but we can combine these
two and you can see this in studies for
example let's take the same example of
diabetes type 2 diabetes you can see
that one of the first g was had you know
maybe thousand patients but the last g
was on diabetes have like 100 000 plus
patients in in that study so so as you
can see we are we are in in this
paradigm shift here but at the same time
you know we also changing our data
source earlier we used to either a lab
will generate a data set they will
analyze that they'll have an insight or
maybe we collect studies like 10 studies
that are related and we do a meta
analysis on that we don't have to be
restricted like that anymore if you have
a good question you can bring in data
from anywhere but there are like data
repositories that are out there
obviously some of them are a commercial
product but some of them like uk biobank
is is completely available for or those
who are interested to ask you know
interesting uh research questions with
that type of data so your bio banks your
bio repositories and then
earlier in the days it was very
difficult to get clinical trial data to
do reanalysis but that is also changing
we now have several projects that tries
to bring in clinical trial data in in an
open access way for example whether
ct.gov or a
aggregate analysis of ct.gov so you can
see that all of that is coming together
and then not just this now we can
measure like
you know typically like you know when we
we run a clinical trial or study when a
patient comes into the hospital we can
measure a few things and then when they
leave the hospital we won't be able to
measure anything anymore but then that's
not the case we now have sensors and
variables which are affordable and
accessible and can be integrated with
your study program and that brings you a
variety of data as well so you just
don't have to restrict to just the omic
data that you typically measure in the
lab setting you don't have to restrict a
clinical data that you capture in a
hospital setting you can now get into
the real world and collect data from
there so that's that's one of the gist
of the changes that we are seeing right
now and you know this is why this is
possible right now because we see a huge
shift in the technology landscape and a
lot of technologies are kind of kind of
growing up growing together thanks to
access to high performance computing and
and whether it's through cloud or local
or a hybrid approach or you know
advances in you know both the biology as
well as technology like i mentioned
whether it's you know better natural
language processing approaches like you
can mine a large amount of data together
you you can you have you know more
intuitive data models available you can
you can have
a precise integration governance and
security to ensure that the data is
being accessed in a privacy preserved
manner since these are all possible
right now thanks to all of that that
that progress but when we come to drug
discovery development and repositioning
what's all possible so this is a this is
just an example of what's possible if we
bring in ai uh into the the whole uh you
know enterprise of developing drugs so
you can you can you can definitely
definitely help in normal therapeutic
agent discovery you can do precision
disease stratification for example
within a population of
who are the disease population within
that disease population what's the
subset of patients that need a treatment
a versus treatment b you can do
integration of multi-homic data which we
will see today and then we can also use
the same type of technology to you know
understand that you know how how
physicians are utilizing the therapies
that we develop when like i mentioned
you know when a patient is not within a
hospital not an ordinary trial we can
still monitor them if they're you know
using an approach is called continuous
remote monitoring and diagnostics and
then also we can plan design and
optimize our trials as uh you know using
uh ai-based that processor so it's it's
so just to kind of give a broad overview
that ai is being applied across this
enterprise of of drug development
but you know due to the time constraints
we'll only focus
today on the integration of multi-omic
data and we see a few examples on that
and even within within this particular
focus area as you can see that you know
there are a lot of possibilities here
but we will pick three examples like i
mentioned the first two are published
one and the last one it knows it's an
ongoing project want to share and give
you an early view into the project and
and you know thanks to our um
leadership this is you know currently
being developed as an open access
project we'll be talking more and more
about these projects like these type of
community activities and and will be
will be happy to share the tour with you
all and would be great to hear uh from
you about you know about the tool in in
hopefully before end of this fall that's
our plan
okay before you know so that's sort of a
background of my talk so i'm going to
talk about three examples today this is
my first example for those who are new
to the whole genomics genomics clinical
genomics-based drug discovery this is a
quick example uh you may have heard
about loss of function variance these
are genetic variants that could lead to
an average rna product and what happens
is that you will end up with a
non-functional pro protein product and
this the concept is there in the
literature we have seen that it's been
successfully used to find targets and
and and now being translated to
therapies across the industry in you
know that you can see and then the the
key three approach that loss of function
could enable is you can probe biology
you can
there is a loss of function that leads
to uh you know variant that leads to a
you know let's say uh loss of functional
protein product would that lead to a
particular phenotype what is its
clinical implication can we use that
approach to develop a therapy these are
the things we can do with the laws of
functional approach and there's a
there's a lot a lot of research has
happened over the last few years but
what we were interested this is a you
know
work that i've done uh in collaboration
with my colleagues from mount sinai
the reason was that what we wanted to
know was like let's say if we have
hospital based clinical data and then
also have a biobank that's linked with
clinical and genomic data so what you
have really is genomic and genomic
information and then you know you
obviously need for this type of study
you need an external validation databank
let's hold that for a second and then i
also have data from public repositories
whether it's genotype phenotype tissue
association and then i can also if i do
identify some significant signal maybe i
can go and test it in an in vitro
testing or in vivo testing actually so
this is this is in a way one of the
workflow that we have generally
leveraged here so we started with a a
database that includes demographic data
this is diagnostic lab test results drug
information and all that kind of comes
from data warehouse and then also uh you
know
more than 11 000 patients with their you
know
genomic information as well so the
question that we were interested in that
we wanted to understand if there is any
loss of functional variance or you know
there are a few already that's been
reported but is there anything that we
could find from our own because our
buyback is a little bit unique on its
own so what i want to understand you
know if you look into these these few
uh you know cardio metabolic traits can
we identify a few uh loss of function
examples so you have a lot of challenges
with that because
we're really handling here with very
messy type of data there will be
incorrect values medication effects and
we used an approach called computational
phenotyping we you know the long story
short we clean the data the data is now
ready for computing and then you know we
did a simple modeling approach gene by
trade association as you can see in the
equation and then you know let's say if
i'm interested in a loss of function
variant in upper
or c3 the you know compared to a wild
type variant as you can see that the
patients with the loss of function
variant
have a in a significantly reduced
triglyceride effect so that's a classic
example everybody knows that and it has
implications in developing therapies and
all but then we then we looked at a
variety of them like we we indeed
replicate some of the you know some of
the big ones whether it's pcsk9 or
upperc3 but we also find something new
as well so we basically like you know
kind of
integrated that data like the
the the kind of phenotype data and then
did some candidate association and then
what we did what we identified was
we found a particular variant in
a gene called dgat2 could lead to uh you
know in a way significant lobbying in
glucose level so we we kind of followed
that up with both uh you know
experimental studies and then what
happened was that we were able to find
one gene like especially based on these
these these approach with the validation
that you know so our knockdown study
suggests that you get you as a potential
target for glucose lowering therapy and
we
we have identified a few others as well
let's say for if you're interested in
lowering triglycerides we found
something uh a few genes including rm
rnm tl1 scrn2 pck2 as potential targets
for lower core so think about it this is
only a small database and it's a fairly
large ehr data but like the linked data
is very small and uk biobank has just
released with hundreds of thousands of
patient samples so really i i want each
and every one of the students in this
call to kind of think about what's
what's that you know most curious
question that you want to ask data is
never never a problem like data is
always available it's really how
creative you can be how curious you can
be and then you can ask these type of
questions and you can take it to either
a therapy a mechanism or a target so
that's just my one of my first example
and then the other uh potential theme i
want to discuss and this is again uh so
those who have heard about repositioning
this might be a little boring for those
who are hearing this for the first time
repositioning is an approach where we
take an approved or or a drug in insert
drug or a therapeutic in a certain stage
of development we take that drug we see
we investigate whether that drug could
work for any other indication and like
you can see in literature a ton of
examples like that and then uh what we
can do is like if you could identify
that using
a drug that's an advanced stage of
development you know that could could
potentially be developed into a therapy
for a new disease so we could
potentially save some development years
and then also uh the cost time and
energy too but at the same time you
still have to repositioning is not just
not just a computational part but you
have to do
downstream analysis downstream uh
clinical trial but the time to trial is
what we are going to save actually
rather than it's not like when when we
hear about repositioning don't think
that it's an experimental approach where
we do uh completely in silico that's not
the purpose or the aim of repositioning
you can do that but really the value
will come when you take it to a trial
and then there are a lot of different
ways to do repositioning and one
approach that we've been focusing on
this type of a molecular match making
approach using a a you know one type of
data here this is primarily
transcriptomic data so we we can
generate what we call as
drug signatures and this is signature
and the idea is that you know using uh
you know statistical learning approaches
can we identify a you know let's say
this is the disease signature for let's
say you know disease two and i want to
find a direct signature that could
reverse these these red to green and
maybe this is a good good track
candidate for this particular disease so
can you do that type of a molecular
matchmaking for that and then we were
interested in repositioning and did one
of the one of the largest meta-analysis
in the space and what we found and i
want each and every one of you to think
about this
and tell me your thoughts also when we
looked at around 200 or so
200 plus repurposed agents across 1100
diseases what we found when we did a
post-hoc analysis
these three purposes let's say i have
drug disease one and disease two and
they that can be potentially targeted
using drug eggs
they are more likely to have
shared genetic architecture for 31
percentage of them more than 31 we saw
that and then again around 27 percentage
we saw that that's those two diseases
when you look into the the pathways they
share we saw pathway crosstalks we
quantified them and then the most
interesting part just like you know by
integrating the molecular data with esha
data what or clinical data what we found
was
if two diseases are comorbid we see the
most commonly within a patient
population they're more likely to uh
potentially be repurposable this is not
a hard and fast rule for it but again
you know the the there is there is some
evidence that's coming in these are the
areas where you should potentially look
when you when you're planning your
infrastructure investigation and why
repositioning works because one of the
potential reason representing work is
because it's a it's you know clear
trophy platoon is a key biological
phenomenon you know and
where one gene could influence two or
more seemingly unrelated phenotypic
traits and that might be the reason why
you know and and then the genes are
doing different functions in different
settings so when you put to using you
know uh one drug against two disease
maybe there is a better uh targeting
strategy there so just for you to think
about it
and as an example so we recently you
know this is again a work that we've
done at mount sinai so here what we did
was in collaboration with my friend and
colleague uh kamala shadow who is now at
texas a m
and what we did was we're interested to
come up with a therapeutic strategy for
a rare uh form of prostate cancer so we
we did some public data analysis
identified some gene expression data
from geo and then we basically run our
repositioning algorithm we were able to
identify you know some of these uh some
of these drugs and then what we found
was interestingly
an alkaloid of course that naturally
long uh black pepper a compound called
piper leukemia was doing really bad good
in our some of our viability essays and
when we looked into the literature and
we saw that you know this is this could
be a potential target because there's
there's already been a ton of data on
this in the literature so we went ahead
and built a mouse model for this unique
sort of rare cancer type and was able to
show that you know the the drug did have
uh uh have an effect as well so it's
really like you know this is again one
of the example i wanted to share with
you and in a similar way
if you're passionate about a particular
disease of interest i would highly
highly encourage to include
repositioning as a potential strategy in
your in your research
so the last part that what i want to
cover today is we live in like we have
seen that like we live in a world of you
know data in flux and we we have uh you
know this challenge of you know uh
we have more data is being generated but
there is a huge delay in inference from
this data what i meant by that is let's
say my friends and colleagues in
microbiome or you know genomic sciences
or trans you know
or multi-organics group generating these
different types of data they know what
their microbial signature is related
with associated with the disease they
know their their genetic variance they
know their transcriptomic signals but
they never they and then they interpret
them independently they never put it
together and look biology in a more
connected way but biology actually
operated in this level it's an
integrated approach but what can we do
about it and on top of that forget about
like along with ohmic data we also have
like custom as a data company like
astronautical for that matter any other
pharma company will have some custom
essays imaging data phenotypic data
clinical data you name it and then
instead of analyzing them independently
can we analyze them together this is a
question that's been you know
really
been challenging for us and just like
the the entire industry here and uh when
we started our group you know one of the
first uh group that reached out to us
our microbial sciences group reached out
to us and asked hey hey can you and your
team help anything with this and i was
like really happy because there's going
to be ton of data on this you know we
can we can apply some deep learning
approach and then what i realized was uh
interestingly the sample numbers are
always very very small and then you have
this classic uh you know analytical
challenge where you have small n and a
large p
and then what happened and then we did
an extensive search in literature survey
and identified that you know why we
cannot really use single techniques and
then
just make a bigger or better version of
that
but they do not take you know
statistically into the you know
integration aspect and then they do not
find relationship between the omics so
what we realized was maybe we need to
make a list wish list of these omics
approaches and then potentially come up
with a way
that we could you know then we used to
um you know uh in
integrate analyze and interpret this
data set so
what we thought was okay let's let's
write our our wish list here so we
started with this sort of this list and
we what we found was there are three key
ways that you can do ohmig data
integration you can do an early
integration you can do an intermediate
integration or you can do a late
integration but then what happens was
that it doesn't matter what you know
what type of integration use you choose
we also want to make sure that the data
represented in each of these you know uh
data or omicronomic type
should be equivalent one nomic should
not dominate you can still wait to your
or mix if you want and they should be
generalizable it should not be only work
for you know transcriptomic or ngs based
techniques or it should only work for
imaging based techniques and then we
need to do variable selection on each
block and then you know in in a way that
we have to also do predictive modeling
on top of that and and two of the key
part was like you have to understand the
relationship between in different types
of formics and then also
you know it should not be confined to
only ohmic data but other types of data
should also be able to add and then you
know we
we came up with this approach we did an
extensive literature survey and then
instead of developing something brand
new what we thought was we start with
the within with a pretty decent package
and then add features that doesn't exist
in it so we basically
start with something called diablos as
you can see that we have some objective
and subjective classification approach
that we took here and then you know we
identified certain algorithms that could
go in there and then with that
on top of that we have built some
additional layers as well so these are
the key features we can do a lot of
normalizing and scaling within our mix
world you can do single single ohmic
multivariate modeling you can do
multi-ohmic multimedia modeling you also
come up with a new
strategy let's say you've done all these
analysis then you can actually do what
we call as a block crank and identify
the best features from that and best
model and it's more stable model and
then you can go do downstream
experimental validation as well so so
this is in a way i don't have time to go
through everything but what i can do is
this is a sort of a broad overview as
you can see here we have a lot of you
know
different types of ohmic data can be on
border once you do you know
pre-processing and then you can do two
types of analysis or rather three types
of analysis you can do if you don't know
the class label you don't have a class
label it's fine you can do unsupervised
exploration if you understand what's
your classes you can do supervised
exploration and go all the way to the to
the marketing part if you want to
do you know cross data set prediction
you can build models whether it's random
forest so you can support rect in your
network you can do that so and then in
addition to that we have other models
that we're building towards you know
understanding the gene sets and
repositioning and all of that as well so
this is in a way what we want to do here
really is to
address the challenge in this biological
data interpretation problem so the
features are interpretable three things
if you have to you know take take away
from my talk so interpretable features
relationship between omic tapes it can
be inferred and it's scalable to add
neonic types we have done so far done
integrated with 12 types of data and we
strongly believe that you can add more
types of data as well so this is a quick
example like this is the dummy data sets
that we have put together so you can see
we have
control zero positive and and disease uh
for for a cohort and then this is uh our
initial model we do model selection and
tuning models get better do better
separation the first one is using the
this one is using mono-ohmic data and
this is using multi-ohmic data you can
see that and in addition to that we have
an array of normal visualization
approaches you can also understand the
stability of these models as well here
and then this is what's available we
will be sharing this with the community
very soon and watch this space
and with that you know i would like to
come to the summary uh i strongly
believe uh
you know biomedical healthcare or data
science is is is it can actually
optimize accelerate reduce the cost of
development as you've seen
a lot of examples today and i'm sure
you're seeing hearing a lot more exams
throughout this this symposium and as
data scientists be ready to push the
limit of your comfort zone it's a team
sport right like we all all need
different types of idea to push the
limits because we don't know what we're
going to find and that's the joy of uh
being a data scientist and then the more
creative you are you know the good
handle of subject subject matter
expertise that you have you can
definitely bring in a lot more value
and then you know definitely biology in
biology everything is connected it's
important to ask a bigger and bolder
question and one more thing we are
always hiring always looking for
collaborators and and will be uh you
know
potentially looking for interns and and
apprenticeship positions and all looking
to feel all of that so please be in
touch you can find me on linkedin or
twitter and we'll be in touch uh
if you would like to connect and we'll
be happy to stay in touch
and you know i would like to acknowledge
my my team from seneca and for the other
two examples to the team from
mount sinai and with that
i'll be happy to take any questions
thank you
great well thank you very much for this
great talk and uh
a couple of questions so first of all a
personal question how did you personally
end up at astrazeneca and uh kind of can
you briefly describe your path
oh sure yeah so
uh
yeah in a way
i wanted to be a software engineer uh
when i was you know
from straight out of my high school
thank you for asking that question so
and then
but i took biology for my high school
so in india i'm originally from india in
india you cannot really go to computer
science uh with the biology background
so you have to do some kind of an
undergrad in in a non-biology background
and then go to computer science so and
then i i went to an undergrad in physics
and then when i was doing physics second
year or third year of physics i heard
that there is this subject called
bioinformatics that combines
uh you know uh computer science and
medicine i'm like wow that's fascinating
that's really really exciting thing
and then um
and i wanted to get into a master's in
bioinformatics so i instead of going to
computer science i completed my master's
in bioinformatics and i did my grad
school from india under professor
sadamni like national center for
biological sciences
and i worked primarily on building
machine learning models to understand
protein sequence structure and
interactions
and then i
i want you know while i i did that work
i wanted to kind of
get experience with other type of data
and that prompted me to go to mayo
clinton for my postdoc
and i was trained with this whole ehr
based data genomic it was at the
beginning of the whole uh sort of
genomic medicine christian medicine
phase in the us which we were one of the
first site for
a project called emerge electronic
medical records and genomics like 12
years ago and was part of that
participated in several clinical trials
and then uh eventually switched to
industry uh you know at a certain point
we've been doing uh some consulting and
eventually to industry and uh i'm with
az for now three years the reason i
joined az three years ago az was
starting the data science group and we
were like only uh maybe like you know my
my including myself and my boss we were
like three members now we are around 60
and now now the whole data science in ai
is actually 150 plus in natural seneca
so we have grown a lot and and really
really excited to bring
you know to see the power of you know
data science and ai
in in in drug discovery so this you know
i still remember
you know in one of the early days of my
my master's in bioinformatics idea that
we are going to see precision medicine
every hospital will have a
bioinformatics team which is something
i've seen happening right now you you
can see that ngc is in every hospital i
mean like in one way or the other the
physicians are using that in like one
way or the other so so we're really
there i mean like this is our moment and
uh um yes that's that's the long story
in a short way thank you
all right great thank you for that uh so
okay so we do have another question um
you mentioned that you
did your postdoc at
a mayo clinic and how different is it
working kind of in basic research as
opposed to you know clinical type
information i mean how uh how different
is the thinking and you know the need
there in terms of omics data
so so definitely like you know in in uh
compared to the uh compared to the basic
science group where we primarily work
with you know genes proteins and
computers that's where that's what we
were working on here you have patient
data too but at the same time you have
to think about what is patient data in
the end what you capture in an ehr data
is nothing but
think of it like a
large long experiment
right like you know you're you're
measuring biomarkers you're measuring
imaging data you're measuring other
types like you know medication data
these are all different types of data
that you measure from your patient
cohort that's being compiled into
you know
not always a user-friendly database you
always need to do a lot of processing
because there's a lot of human errors
because this will be either typed in or
translated by you know an automated
transcription engine you have a lot of
clinical notes that you can mine through
so so there are a lot of a lot of that
pre-processing is required but in the
end the way that i thought about that
was you know this is pretty much like an
experimental data but it's coming from
you know a physician and patient
encounter
you know and and that's how i kind of
thought through that and now what we're
seeing that we you know when we were
back at mayo the the challenge was to
put genomic data into electronic health
record we have achieved that you know
it's there and everybody's aware and we
still need more training we still need
the accessibility is not global we need
to improve that all of that is for true
but
now the field of the experimental
biology is moving in at much faster pace
and as you can see that like i mentioned
biology is now more digital biology and
we have that gap they're generating more
and more data
we're not able to interpret them on time
so how do we do that and that's where
approaches like omix fold and you know
these these kind of strategies and
need needed and again we cannot do it by
ourselves we need collaborations we need
to work with the community and and and
and i really appreciate this invitation
to kind of share our research with you
all yeah
great thank you another question uh so
while recruiting for bioinformatic roles
in astrozenica is a phd an advantage or
should you have only a master's degree
we
we have you know i can i can speak for
the group that i am part of like what we
are data science and artificial
intelligence so we have a a a
senior senior data scientist principal
data scientist and then as assistant
director as a director senior director
and an executive director all the way up
to the vp that's sort of our career
level in in data science we don't have
an absolute requirement for for for a
pst so if you're very good at you know
within in in some of the technical
skills or scientific skills have
you know a a passion to work on solving
the type of problems uh that are related
to drug discovery development and
repositioning or even in the under and
their enterprise of
of drug development including clinical
trials or patient recruitment we we we
hire you know both both phds and masters
it's a it's not just you know um
even we have undergrads too like a very
few undergrads too
okay perfect